we do have Darius verch with us in the
studio Darius a difficult encounter with
a very well prepared Sam shanglin he
surprised you with this uh groom felt no
he didn't surprise me with the group it
does surprise me I actually was
expecting it I mean some place many
openings of course his trustable courses
on semislava are like really famous I
was looking outside other openings but
yeah grunfels was one of his main
openings and I was expecting I was
already expecting it so uh yeah I had
this line Bishop C4 prepared and
actually and I thought
all right it's an interesting try for
sure
um
and uh yeah this E6 line that some
played uh yeah it's uh don't you buy a
surprise no I was not surprised actually
uh
I guess I can say it uh I analyze it
very deeply for my upcoming Festival
course oh so I've never talked about for
a while so uh yeah here is exam is one
of the lines that I analyzed pretty
deeply and actually I had a game like
this already two weeks ago which is
probably not published or like it's
maybe hard to find but I had a game
against the attack actually I played
tournament in Poland two weeks ago the
rapid tournament in Poland and uh yeah
this was uh this is what yazak played
against me and I managed to win this
game so it was exactly up to move like
uh 14. so yeah Bishop B3 and now yeah so
basically played against me in this
position Bishop B5 which is a big
mistake uh because right now Rook takes
d8 Rook takes d8 94 and uh the problem
is that right now let's say we should
goes to A6 or something and I can play
with F4 which is a very important detail
because there is no Knight G4 and
usually this person you want to play
Knight G4 but in this case you can do
this because there is Knight X E6 very
nice so so this is one of the main ideas
uh and after a four wide General
speaking better of course the game goes
on but what is better but some played
Bishop C6 pretty quickly and I could not
recall what is like my exact analysis
there I just could not recall at all and
I believe that some worked out to a draw
or something but still I thought that
this is uh I mean I'm sure I had it in
my analysis for trustable course but I
just could not really recall this again
like some like 2021 Bishop G4 Bishop D7
I couldn't play E6 so really it was
difficult for me to you know anticipate
everything and I just did not remember
this particular position with 56 so I
played a three which I thought which
felt right look at this year is probably
correct and he played it quickly he
played also very quickly yes and here I
had made really a lot of a lot of
options I've had 94 interesting either
four interesting I have rookie B1 I mean
I just I mean really really vast choice
but I just
uh I mean I didn't remember I analyzed
for sure I just didn't remember and uh
yeah I decided to play on the four and I
think it was a decent try a 504 is
usually good for black to include these
moves uh Bishop E8 yeah and this was the
first move that Sam actually thought
about yeah yeah so I thought it was good
news that he finally he's thinking yeah
of the book uh yeah King F1 never never
crossed my mind of course uh king of one
yeah I don't know how great it is but
is just equalizing immediately which
probably this but I my suspicions to
some game I guess I don't know
um I don't know I'm just not sure after
King to F1 actually the best move is
Bishop page six anyway so he does seem
like he knew about this he knew any
ideas I was I wasn't familiar already so
anyway I played this visual D4 which
felt pretty natural and here and I think
it was very strong move and yeah here I
spent lots of time calculating at 86 and
I was really tempted to do this and but
my the reason why I didn't do this is
King f8 the takes takes takes on G7
probably and not the the things that you
have to Rook a B1 if some place Rook C7
or something I played will be five and
I'm winning or somewhere exactly it's
winning yeah I thought I have very good
chances here to be one there's no way
basically he cannot regroup but the
point is that he has knight d8 uh
instead of seven idea and he's managing
to establish beautiful C6 night Bishop
Knight comes to E6 and all my weaknesses
are just collapsing absolutely so uh
okay engine gives zero zero but I
thought if anyone's taking any risk here
is zero zero after Rook takes d8 which
is not yeah actually I was thinking
about it I also specifically this could
be a draw but uh again it's not
something I want to play right so that's
for this reason I decided not to do this
and
yeah actually it's very one more
important detail here after Knight takes
E6 because it may be tempting to play
after Bishop B6 Bishop F7 but visual 7
is a big mistake because uh in the same
position I play Indian Rook D7 I
think this is a very important detail
exactly uh I saw that during the game
and as far as firm winning but I
realized Bishop is not someone's to keep
the bishop needed comes to these six and
it's I'm not playing this for a win for
sure yeah so uh this is what I was
thinking so I said in the end decided to
keep it simple deck on G7 play 93
because I wasn't sure how he's gonna
establish I mean like how he's gonna
capture my opponent C5 of course I saw
that B96 or not being a D7 but I've had
that Bishop C4
97 should be five and I fought here like
in the end of this car like exchanges
and so on I have room design and he
still needs to be a bit careful which
probably is true if he doesn't say on
like Rook ACA let's say probably I don't
know exactly I was asking group B1 or
something I can play and he is in some
trouble uh but very precise Rook 88 is
just pretty much recording into a draw
right away yeah and the rest of the game
I mean it was we played a couple of more
moves but yeah uh it's just the drawer
so Doris how would you assess your form
up to this point and based on the first
couple of games yeah I feel pretty good
I feel pretty good yeah yesterday I had
very interesting game against Jeffrey
and I was I mixed up my opening but uh I
mean yeah I was in big trouble actually
strategically but in the uh critical
moment I've decided to play this move E5
which actually as I checked later was a
good try and I'm surprised to see that I
mean I
I'm surprised to see there's no losing
sort of because I just found my I felt
really shaky at this moment like one
person was very shaky but uh after
Jeffrey didn't take this Pawn or I
played E4 actually engine is giving the
black is better and I had no I couldn't
I didn't realize that sort of that's why
I played kind of a couple of passive
nothing very possible I stay in place
trying to get 40 and in this basically
just end up with let's say a bit Wars
end game but definitely holdable because
just such a blockade on B5 must give me
drawing choices but again if I if I
realize I'm better I would definitely
come up with I mean I saw of course the
idea of 96 95.93 and I wanted to do that
but the question is if I'm in time
because captured my pollen A4 so it was
not obvious to me at the board I said to
play something safer as well give me
another draw but overall I am I feel
good I feel really good so I'm looking
forward to more games still the start of
the tournament a very long tournament
ahead of yourself a good luck games
thank you and good luck indeed I just
want to turn